Jesus why is there so much marble in
this DC logo
he went out to fix his shutters in the
pouring rain what he couldn't predict
was that he'd fall in love Jules Verne
once Roe aquamarin put two ships in the
open sea without wind or tide and will
come together look I'm not as much of a
seaman as Jules Verne was seaman but
since is this me the lack of wind and
the tide and gate the very idea of
nautical unity someone doesn't like the
idea of spinning off Florence's
character from The Jeffersons into two
to seven so who are you Vanna queen of
Atlantis I'm Tom keeper of Lighthouse
this just goes to show that men will go
along with any crazy if the woman is hot
enough the lighthouse this is a wreck
penis but in my father's lighthouse she
found something unexpected Jango Fett
also movie sure did yada yada Atlanta's
whole integration into human society huh
I know they're in love and Donna's just
accepted her entire backstory about
underwater royalty and my father on the
love of his life well as long as two
completely different species can be
successfully what's the heart hi Jim
peasant one day a new king will come
nursery rhymes position I would love to
have known what the investigative
process was that led this aquarii army
to this location after three years of
fruitless searching all things
considered this is a pretty badass
action scene it definitely plays with
special effects to make Moulin Rouge
look like a bonafide action star but
I'll take this over the keyword marvel
fight scene anytime whoa whoa take it
easy there Atlanta your husband brings
in lighthouse money they will always
find me I always leave way too much of a
credit card paper trail fake fish hey
fish fish in case you confused it with
the Boston aquarium and smack over
Arkansas author it's talking to the fish
easy boys even though this is a movie
set in New England it is not based on a
bully filled novella by Stephen King
being honest how many people at the
aquarium actually saw Arthur's eyes turn
yellow they're from this distance maybe
one or two but certainly not enough to
get a collective gasp right and why did
in government agencies immediately
descend to study the magical talking
Sharkboy I won't tell you how to captain
and you don't tell me how to pirate was
the point of keeping this asshole alive
if not specifically so that Kane can
announce himself as a pirate I never
told you the story behind it so I will
right now mid plunder because I'm pretty
sure I'm gonna die in the next five
minutes have these pirates never
actually pirated before sure Aquaman's a
badass but if they attacked him in any
other way than this bull there's no way
he'd be winning this fight wait did
Aquaman use that bad guy's arms to turn
the hatch on this door King why why did
Kane wait this long to open fire his
crews been dead for at least several
minutes right we'll see him to luxury in
this whole town man
roll Z Turtles knowing what Aquaman
strength is in this movie does Manta
survive this even if this is
substantially less force than it took
him to say push a submarine to the
surface this is still a crushing
somebody's skull type of a move correct
hey movie get your Zack Snyder out of my
James Wan also Aquaman survives this I
guess he is impervious to bullets
even though Justice League didn't tell
us that but this was a direct hit from
one of those big guns like what took out
the t1000 damn it Arthur should be dead
as disco right now not temporarily stunt
there's no one fine
you mean at his house good thinking how
is it that I can breathe underwater but
still drink on the table Oh casual
familiar alcoholism and here in Maine
they call that bonding of the Navy's
highly classified prototype stealth
submarine
I'm really fuckin sick of movies using a
stupid-ass bar TV that suddenly turned
to the relevant news story and it
somehow achieved full volume to expose
it all over our faces it's not me how
does Thomas not know this this is after
Justice League so the entire world saw
them resurrect then fight Superman in
Metropolis need that fish boy from the
TV these guys just want a picture and it
subverts the dumbasses in a bar pick a
fight with the metahuman trope we've
seen time and again but who
ask for a picture this way oh cool
they're all arriving for this year's
Triwizard Cup ah sudden um who is that
kind of looks familiar but I can't make
it out
holy does that leafy terraces Patrick
Wilson actually make that noise and in
water how does the noises you even work
down here it's not even like Justice
League we're pineapple express made an
air bubble for and Arthur to talk just
in the water
his loyalty is to the stuff later we
find out that arm conspired with Manta
to make it look like humans were
attacking an underwater city so there
seems to be a huge flaw in this plan
like for instance Manta could have
potentially killed or it takes special
skill to make effects look this should
be well being this dark and murky I'm
almost impressed explosion you can just
go through them as long as the missile
didn't make contact with you and someone
blew it up first we see Mira walking
from the water and then the grand
entrance well even cause that splash did
she get to the beach and say Arthur
won't know I'm here unless I make a
splashing noise go back deeper into the
water then jump back out volcko has
learned to the location of the lost
trident of Atlantis with the sacred
trident the people will listen to you
what supreme executive power derives
from a mandate from the masses not some
farcical aquatic ceremony all so can I
just start going up I'm an aquaporin
from now on I might lapse into that time
and again I'm not married to it fairy
tales it's a myth is it really possible
to even have fairy tales in a world
where Atlanteans exist like after
watching superheroes some of whom were
actual deities defeat alien threats how
does anyone say no but it's too
unbelievable for me driving that
submarine was barely operational but it
served its purpose one of your kind
intervened
so wait you're telling me that Manta
used the Russian submarine that was
flooding and that he left sinking the
last time we saw it his dad also blew up
a grenade where all the missiles were
stored how do you get that thing working
also Oh No
now even the water people are using
Holograms for communications what is
calling them water people and sensitive
is that racist ah stupid Holograms also
also why'd it take five soldiers to
deliver this hard candy gram
look I've never personally been in a
tsunami but I'm willing to bet that it
makes some noise Arthur could hear the
birds but not this giant wave that's
currently wrecking the shit out of a
large fishing boat I could give the
movie a million sins for how dark and
murky the action it is but because I'm
in a good mood I'm only gonna give it
now say 15 presidented Sykes from all
over the world today all over the world
now does warm have that much reach I get
that he can pull some from the Atlantic
but see going to like Peru Mumbai
Djibouti decades of pollution has been
thrown back on the land
oh cool we have time for a ham-handed
environmental message in this movie
luckily it's nearly two and a half hours
long why is this junk necessary they
could jump into any area of the water
and swim to Atlantis but they choose the
one we're jumping into the jagged rocks
below as a possibility
hit my ship in here do you need a ship
for both of you our ships later on we
see that they need to pass some sort of
security protocol in Atlantis but
wouldn't set security work a lot better
without use of ships things that people
who swim like fish don't need and can't
hide contraband or stowaways in this
ship has been marinating in chum butter
weird this is the same thing I said to
my college girlfriend after the first
time we had sex without a condom oh
that's a Bifrost underwater out I can't
wait until Thor dukes it out with
Aquaman for the throne of sexiest cum
book character alive Atlantis is pretty
well populated right but really the only
traffic we saw over the cargo sea
turtles and the rest of the time drive
angry can zip all over the place with no
impedance this should look like the city
in the fifth element we use this air
pocket as an extra layer of precaution
only the highborns can breathe water as
well as air I can guarantee you there is
at least one Ethan Hawke and Gattaca
type that can breathe air and wood if it
weren't for his asshole father the
cylinder bears the markings of the
dezerter kingdom you must take it there
and retrieve the message Oh for fuck's
sake what in volcko get this done
already
they found the recording months ago blue
to add lens final resting place is
inside of this less than an hour and
this is the third surprise explosion
knocking people down instance in this
b-movie and it's getting extremely
annoying
hilariously incompetent way to restrain
Arthur you seriously don't have any
static objects that are hard to move
that they can attach these chains to the
century hey humans have been polluting
the water for much longer than a century
also this magical video presentation is
ready to give you visual confirmation of
the humans destruction right here in
front of you if you want to see Basic
Instinct in true 3d I've got that
brother we could play it right now and
pristine unicorn 8k but it's fine when
you're over it still awesome it's not
like I didn't see a much better version
of this pissing contest earlier in the
year and black panther there's way too
much of this do we really have to have
an extended rocky montage of Arthur's
adolescent training this could have been
a tight fun romp was Arthur remembering
that his mom got killed I think about
strategy or fighting underwater I'm sure
you're ready to fight why not fire how
does it work instead of bitching at him
for getting into this fight did volcko
seriously and not tell him anything
about the fight well he was scorned my
betrothed to the Royal boss doesn't she
already have the Royal Box though Wow
how do the Atlanteans get kneel down
here you love our mothers trident
powerful but flawed like her I guess
it's not really Patrick Wilson's fault
but he sure does have like 40% too much
dialogue in this movie
hey have you ever wanted to watch a same
vs same fight with middling effects but
also one of the puke your guts out
welcome to the scene looks like they cut
out the scene where Clint Eastwood could
tell just by hearing Aquaman swing that
he has trouble with the curve that's why
Arthur will never make the Atlantis
Braves so they can go anywhere during
this battle what the hell is most of the
crowd even seeing right now was to
recover Allen's tried it then challenged
or okay don't worry this actual
discussion between the screenwriters and
the director finds its way into the
movie also what choice did Arthur have
once Iron Man 1 2 & 3 came in to arrest
him was he supposed to not accept arms
challenge and hang out in prison until
Meera found a lost ridin for him because
as we're about to see that would have
been impossible many seconds of a
waterlogged chase scene with the
prominent involvement of water lasers
yep it's exactly as exciting as it
sounds but even if there's a tracker on
alpha dogs how the hell could he
possibly catch up to them so fast
also it appears that ORMs plan is to
glare these two to death
but she did and she is somehow going to
avoid an unholy phalanx of orange laser
that would be impossible if not for plot
armor this movie is literally playing a
hip-hop cover of Koto's Africa as we pan
over the Saharan desert and I think my
brain just officially curdled so they
stepped out of the ocean looking like
this went to a private Airport and hired
a guy to fly them over the Sahara
without paying up front
the tracking place dispenses matter here
in the desert King the tracker what
dragger you mean the movie crotch
look movie if you're gonna make a big
deal out of mera practically vomiting
because she's never been up this high
before and you can't make her fearlessly
jump out of a goddamn airplane without
any reservations and I know it's Sam
they're about to jump into but now I've
gotta ask what exactly would kill these
two if not this fall oh yeah I remember
this dude that we haven't seen in almost
an hour
no me neither oops major hologram faux
pas there Manta one time obi-wan did
that Toyota and Yoda nearly ended that
motherfucker converts water into beans
of energized plasma so a super soaker
I guess mantas got a manta but isn't
Kane a pirate this montage makes him
look like goddamn Tony Stark when he's
been shown to be a competent but very
straightforward thief look like Club I
know you're new to how things work up
here skip now we are strangers so just
like that eh he just fell down into the
secret world in the middle of the desert
buried by mountains of sand you know
they were given little to no instruction
other than where to go right but they're
doing everything perfectly in order to
complete this inane quest it's
completely dried out now look sometimes
it takes a little while to get things
going try some more for pseudo romantic
banter to see if that helps what are you
doing we need water you need an closest
source now hold still um can't they just
pee on it
do they pee he would think they pee cuz
is peed on you see
no seriously this one tiny fucking drop
of flop sweat powers of this entire
thing that previously had to be under
water to work you should've peed on it
you must prove your worth journey beyond
the edge of the world to the hidden see
this is the exact same quest for
Merlin's staff and transformers the last
night Arthur is wild King Arthur and
this movie is following the same path
the last night did when they went to the
alien ship which was wait for it
underwater
only in the hands of the true king can
he truly see prophesies what did you say
something something trying it's Aquaman
it's supposed to be dumb I know he's
quit be and he drinks a lot but he seems
like he's able to process information
pretty well but in the last few scenes
he's gone completely meathead in case
she confused it with Cicely Tyson no one
will be seated during the a walk in the
clown's portion of the movie so many
assholes so little time Jesus Christ
this is turning into a full-on
live-action version of The Little
Mermaid without my consent and I did not
sign up for that also seriously well
they're dicking around here isn't Warren
still planning to end humanity and this
is the that happens way too much of this
fucking movie your kingdom bloated
philosophers and flaccid poets hey watch
what you say about my university's
liberal arts department Marcos agree pay
there's a great general but it wasn't a
king see he's not stupid and movie
cannot make up its mind if it wants to
be consistent or squeeze a cheap laugh
out of the audience you know all this
stuff as my pops made sure I knew my
history yeah totally the guy who gets
plastered at bars every night and never
once mentioned a historical fact ever in
this entire movie seems like a real
history buff
these guys are kings except this guy
Romulus
why the Atlanteans consider Romulus a
true King and isn't the Aquaman's story
steeped in Greek mythology doesn't the
whole Atlantis mythology come from Plato
but even more important why would they
use human Kings as a guide for their
Trident hunt god dammit stop with a
surprise explosions movie till you learn
your lesson I'm assigning you ten since
I know this is a classic villain outfit
there was an actual reason given about
why the helmet is so big the holy
bejeezus is success stupid luckily for
Mira these soldiers went to the finest
stormtrooper aiming school in Atlantis
also by the way there are no tourists at
this extremely touristy part of Sicily
especially on this beautiful day so that
we're not bothered by that whole Man of
Steel collateral damage issue
black matte or um did you just say Black
Panther oh oh you said Black Manta okay
you're right
totally different I had Marvel's lawyers
on the line there for a second that's
refined me what lady friend has people
who like to keep the time why bother
even telling him this even if you're
sure you're going to kill Aquaman okay I
know it took us in off earlier for the
mama uncle fight scene but this is some
really good stuff I know where the fight
is relative to the other fight I know
where they're running I can see all the
pieces coming together and I can also
take another sin off of this very nice
camera work damn it movie why couldn't
we have more of this will you see an
Aquaman get full blasted by Black Manta
in this movie and he didn't die now
we're supposed to worry when he falls up
a building and hits a bunch of stuff on
the way to the ground what could
actually kill it this is the Superman
problem only worse because his powers
have never been defined wait he's had an
electric harpoon this whole time I
didn't even leave what that Arthur would
never be out of your sights
did you yeah she did I'm kind of
wondering how long that went down to
they were in Sicily and she must have
carried his unconscious body around
while looking for the perfect vessel
look I know time is of the essence here
but why not wait until Arthur became
conscious and swim there they are more
than fast enough to make up the time it
took to sail out here mommy replayed her
aqua flute you think I do not know that
you have spent years training him to
take the throne from me
we saw Oram give the side-eye to volcko
earlier in the movie but otherwise how
does he know this
when does he know this why does he know
this and why does he wait until now to
bring it up but he has time for flower
eating in Italy but can't afford to make
this very simple explanation clear we
interrupt this Aquaman movie to bring
you a very special presentation of pitch
black also a man I take back that what
about me row stealing a boat they needed
those flares they had no idea they'd
need so yeah so that flares just gonna
work underwater huh don't Thunder water
flares require some sort of hose that
supplies oxygen a bubble around the
flame and other science facts
hmm recording from that land say
anything about the whirlpool seems like
if you're going to make people go on a
difficult quest to find some stupid
Trident you tell them about it
especially since there are so many
variables in the sea and this could be
something you're supposed to avoid hey
totally Michelle Pfeiffer Nicole Kidman
- the DC version of the quantum realm
didn't they also how did Atlanta know to
go into the water to save them did she
send something in the force or was she
just swimming around in her Halloween
costume just happened upon her long-lost
son and her other sons ex-fiance more
that sacrificed me to the trench might
survive fought my way through as you did
I ended up here you mean you happen to
have some handy flares to ward off the
creatures willingly swam into the
whirlpool and got brought to the surface
by your mom - it is guarded by the curse
how many quests do we see in movies
where someone like at land sets up a
quest to find a coveted item telling
them only someone who was worthy can
possess the thing and put them through
at least two extremely hard trials only
to tell them now that you're at the
place where the thing is I put one more
giant obstacle in your way it came to
pass then why go through all the other
they've had to go through that if an
unbeatable legendary sea creature is
just going to play bouncer to the
Trident then why all the bullsh free yes
ready after two minutes of
reconciliation that followed 20 years of
abandonment Atlantic and make this
proclamation and send Arthur's ass into
what should be certain death king fights
only first nation you everyone do you
know that we've been on Temptation
Island for 20 years yeah that's right I
pulled out in at least 16 year old
reference to a short-lived trashy
reality show on fuck we they brought
that your back against false kings since
the beginning and for us power
so since these would be Kings needed to
watch a recording and figure out a
puzzle how many of these bottles with
the map did they put down in the floor
for people to find this they're a
never-ending PEZ dispenser of bottles
with maps inside them I have seen the
greatest champions try okay about three
minutes ago we just heard Atlanta say
that she tried to go in here numerous
times but it wouldn't allow her because
she wasn't the true king
so who the are all these dildos what
she's saying wouldn't let her go past
the waterfall or was she saying that she
couldn't beat the Koran because if she
got this far shouldn't she have died no
man has ever freed the Trident from a
clans grip
probably because they were getting their
asses kicked by the captain seriously
why the bold quest if Arthur was the
only one who could pull the sword from
the stone
I mean Trident from the at land because
stuck this thing in the middle of
Atlantis is Town Square and save time
Arthur's transformation into King will
be brought to you by random pictures of
aquatic sea life the Lupus on who
directed Lucy will be extremely happy I
remove 85,000 sins if either Mara or
Atlantis so did you get the tribal oh
man I bet these battle crustaceans are
delicious if they've been living in a
brine all these years these types of
large-scale CGI panels are just noise to
me you might as well put a bunch of
static on the screen see no difference
yeah buddy killing a ton of the innocent
army right I know they started it but
all he's really here for is Corp so you
should just be going after him let's
even need this big angry Kraken thing
for anyway oh man totally about the fish
bone I think also Aquaman and mera
finally kiss and as if the movie is
literally saying due to its audience
there seems to be some sort of magic and
visible bubble keeping them from getting
caught in the crossfire of this raging
battle impossible sure it's impossible
just like the giant Cthulhu that Aquaman
was riding on was impossible a minute
ago stop saying it is impossible when
you've seen previously thought
impossible things Drago
the half-breed wields King Edmonds tried
it he commands the sea then that
half-breed is you King this will be
happy it's like it's a goddamn Harry
Potter movie the giant war crocodile
gets ever closer to Aquaman he wedges a
trident in its jaws to stop him from
eating it but he can talk to this
crocodile right no need for the trident
theatrics hoody gives four full seconds
for audiences to applaud as Aquaman
shamelessly poses in victory
it's a long story I'll tell you later it
really isn't they tried to sacrifice
Atlanta to the creatures of the depths
she survived she's been living on an
island by the hidden sea for twenty
years because the island wouldn't let
her escape without the Trident
the end and I love you but you have been
misguided I mean the first the conjuring
was really good and you could talk me
into the second one after a couple
cocktails but the none was really a
bridge too far you ready
let's talk is this going to be some Thor
Loki in the future not people of
Atlantis today began bloodshed let it
end enjoy I guess one of Mira's powers
is the ability to amplify her voice so
everyone within a half-mile radius can
hear her I am
seems like you could come up with
something cooler than that but we'll go
along with it I guess
Jesus is it a requirement that the skin
character has to go an hour of movie
time between appearances also this guy
is still alive for some reason and why
is he floating on this piece of broken
deck the last time we saw him he got hit
and strangled by a youth ball and chain
tried to bag it but his head went with
it
crashed into a building hit many many
rocks and fell into the water on the
shores of Sicily so he managed to live
through all that and find a piece of
wood to float out into sea while he was
unconscious
if you men only knew oh my god they
found me I don't know however they found
him where I come from miss G carries our
tears away like tears in rain when the
Sun rises in the West and sets in the
east then he should return to me my son
estas and I killed a guy with a trident
pie doggy
he gave it to me when I was your age I
hid this uncomfortable hunk of metal up
my ass two years discharged it's just
beer break it's just very
by the power of Grayskull
that's a huge bitch